this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos created by
nucleus medical media to apply for a
free 30-day trial click on the link in
the description
robotic surgery is a minimally invasive
operation performed by surgeons
manipulating robotic arms through
several tiny incisions called ports
a robotic surgical machine consists of
several main components including
the console where the surgeon sits while
performing the operation
the patient side cart with four
interactive robotic arms and attached
surgical instruments
and a high definition 3d vision system
this system allows surgeons to make
precise controlled movements in your
body with increased vision and dexterity
during robotic surgery your surgeon will
insert a high-definition 3d camera
through one of the ports the camera
provides a magnified view of the
surgical area
then your surgeon will insert
specialized surgical tools held by the
remaining robotic arms through the other
ports
seated at the computer console
your surgeon will view the surgical area
through a viewfinder
and move the surgical tools and camera
with joystick like controls and foot
pedals
your surgeon's motions will generate
computer input to guide the motion of
the robot arms and surgical tools
advantages of the system include
controlled accurate movement of the
surgical tools
prevention of unintentional handshake or
tremor
ability to operate in spaces smaller
than a human hand
enhanced visibility of the surgical area
and less patient blood loss and scarring